we're giving relief to affected
industries and small businesses and
we're ensuring that we emerge from this
challenge with the prosperous and
growing economy because that's what's
going to happen it's going to pop one
day we'll be standing possibly up here
we'll say well we won and we're going to
say that sure as you're sitting there
we're gonna say that and we're going to
win and I think well then win faster
than people think I hope later today
I'll meet with the leaders from the
termined tourism industry as well as
industrial supply retailers and
wholesalers to discuss their critical
roles as you know I met with the
department store people all of the
retailers the big ones including Walmart
and others and it was great meeting
they're stocking up their stores like
they have never stopped them before
we're trying to get people to actually
buy less if that's possible buy less
don't take everything just buy what you
need for a while it's going to stay open
all hours of the day and they've really
been they've been fantastic we're taking
aggressive action now as one nation or
one family so that America can rebound
stronger frankly stronger than ever
before and we recognize that while many
American workers can work from home many
others cannot many of our health care
providers first responders and men and
women in the food service and
manufacturing are showing that they're
showing up and standing up to provide us
with the goods and services we need so
we want people to stay home where they
can but in many cases when you talk
about food service and manufacturing
certain items in particular they are
they're going in and they're practicing
all of the safety rules and regulations
that we talk about